welcome back to CBS mornings where we
have more on the emotional custody
battle over a little girl rescued by
American forces after a 2019 raid in
Afghanistan the child known as baby L is
now three and a half years old and she's
been adopted by an American military
family but an Afghan couple say that
they are the child's rightful family and
they accuse the American Marine and his
wife of unlawfully taking custody of her
the American couple spoke with senior
investigative correspondent Catherine
Herridge in their first TV interview and
Catherine joins us now with part two of
baby Elle's story Catherine I've been
talking about this for 24 hours now I
can't wait to see what part two brings
thanks and good morning when Joshua and
Stephanie Mast met the Afghan couple
caring for baby L it was clear to both
families they were not on the same page
the controversy and confusion around
baby Elm is rooted in two very different
accounts of how her adoption happened
as the Taliban swept through Afghanistan
the mass frantically worked to get the
child out they arranged for the Afghan
couple to bring babyl to the U.S in
August 2021 the mass and the Afghan
couple met face to face for the first
time at Ramstein Air Base in Germany the
Afghan woman was pregnant at the time
we're cleared to take her in Germany and
we chose to let her process through he
kept conveying like my wife is attached
to the child but when she has her baby
she'll be fine and then when his wife
wasn't that's when he changed his tune
basically so the the Afghan male tells
you don't worry about my wife she's
going to have her own baby she's going
to forget about this child exactly from
Germany the Afghan couple flew to
Virginia with babiel and then traveled
to Fort Pickett military base the couple
says in court filings they thought they
were bringing babyl to the U.S for
medical treatment while the mass say
they made it clear the baby out would
become their adopted child did you feel
that you effectively communicated that
you had custody of this child and that
you were legally responsible for the
child in the U.S courts absolutely I
mean they used their military ID and her
U.S name and identity to get to America
it wasn't just Medical Care and so when
he threw out the course of the person
he's like so could she go to university
we're like absolutely so it was the
understanding was very clear that it was
a long-term commitment throughout the
course of a childhood all the way to
adulthood
the child was transferred from the
Afghan couple to the mass at Fort
Pickett by all accounts the encounter
was fraught the Afghan woman broke down
in tears and begged masked not to take
the child I was in the car and so the
statement Department representative
brought
her out to me and I could hear an
urgency in her voice so is it is
everything okay and she's like no
they're getting a little emotional and
then Joshua came out about five minutes
later and upset just visibly just
bothered and he said that was the
hardest thing I've ever had to do
court records indicate the Afghan woman
became depressed and suicidal after the
transfer while the Afghan couple has
declined repeated interview requests
from CBS News in October the woman told
the Associated Press our hearts are
broken we have no plans for a future
without her in messages reviewed by CBS
News the Afghan man told an interpreter
that he felt quote betrayed by mast the
couple also claims in court documents
that the mass fraudulently obtained a
passport for the child how do you
respond to allegations that your family
kidnapped the child I would say they're
false
we have been honest about who we are and
our concerns over the child for the very
first day according to court documents
the Afghan couple eventually relocated
to Texas the woman gave birth to a
daughter not long after babyl was
transferred to the mass she told the
Associated Press that every time she
buys an outfit or present for her
daughter they buy a matching one for
baby L for the last 16 months babiel has
lived with the mass and their four Sons
why are you sharing her story now
I think the reason that we chose to
speak up finally is to just to tell the
real story we're not out to chase down
other allegations or what has been said
about us but just to share from the
heart what she's gone through what our
family's gone through and what why we
did what we did
so to be clear you wanted to stay in the
background but there was a Tipping Point
what was the Tipping Point I think when
the Taliban calls you out by name
and agrees with your opponents about
what should happen to this little girl
that's the point we're going to start
fighting back Joshua must last fall the
town Alabama posted a video claiming
Joshua Mast quote forcefully took baby L
they vowed to seriously pursue the issue
with American authorities so the child
is quote returned to her relatives the
U.S state Department told CBS news that
reuniting the child with the family
members in Afghanistan was the right
thing to do our position at that time as
well as our position now is
straightforward in court papers the
justice department also said granting
the mass custody and Adoption of the
baby are contrary to the foreign policy
interests of the United States and mass
actions were in violation of Virginia
law in the court filings the federal
government has called the custody order
unlawful and improper what's your
response
I vehemently disagree with that
characterization of it
um I don't think any child should be
turned over without a DNA test the
Dan government determined the husband to
be the baby's first cousin but a
Virginia judge in the adoption case
recently found there was no DNA evidence
presented to show any likely family
relation because the Afghan couple had
resisted DNA testing how do you explain
the refusal how do I explain the first I
think they know that they're not
biologically related all right first
official Rider as the case plays out in
the courts the mass priority they say is
keeping babiel safe what's at stake
her future her future absolutely her
life you know I would say that her
everything is at stake and so we're
going to continue to defend her just
like with any of our other children
the Virginia judge also found that the
Afghan couple can challenge the final
adoption because they cared for the
child for 18 months but noted there are
still questions to be answered on both
sides adoption laws in Virginia are very
strict and after six months adoptions
are generally considered final
successful challenges are extremely rare
in a three and a half year old which is
babiel's age now same age as Teddy
you're chatty you're aware if you've
been living with this film for 18 months
any kind of movement out of there is
going to be hard
but on the contrary they spent nearly
the same amount of time living with the
Afghanistan right at a younger age and a
much younger age but the Afghan family
doesn't want to present any DNA evidence
number number one and number two there
this only became an issue because both
of her parents excuse me were killed in
the war
correct so that's why she's an orphan
and as Gail mentioned yesterday things
Can't Get Lost in Translation yeah but
it seems like there's so much he say she
say with how their accounts aren't
matching up yeah when it comes there are
a lot of conflicts in the accounts we
could be looking at state and federal
trials uh within the next year year and
a half whatever the outcome it's likely
it could be appealed so it's shaping up
to be a years-long process what what I
would say
is that it's clear from our reporting
that so many parties are invested in
this child yeah the Afghan family the
mass the military service members the
nurses the doctors that helped care for
her but the justice department doesn't
appear to be supporting the justice
department is very clear that they feel
that this adoption should never have
happened and they say it's a violation
of U.S foreign policy interests I hope
the trashcan family hasn't proven that
they're really related to this little
girl and the prospects for a little girl
in Afghanistan are not very good as
we've reported on on this show right but
the Afghan couple is living here in the
United States right now well they were
paroled into the United States almost
two years ago be two years ago in August
the Department of Homeland Security
can't discuss specific cases but there
is a process to ultimately decide
whether they would remain in the U.S
she's clearly loved by two families Love
by two families yeah she is boy that's
complicated thank you Catherine you're
welcome it's good to see you